alright I'm gonna give this a shot let's
start with number of critical resources
we've got HTML CSS and JavaScript so
that seems like there are three critical
resources okay
total critical bytes we've got five
kilobytes for HTML four for CSS and two
for JavaScript so that's going to be 11
total kilobytes and then minimum
critical path length or round trips
let's see hmm is it going to be 2 or 3
can the browser download both the CSS
and JavaScript in parallel it's sue the
browser can download both files in
parallel note that the number of
critical resources and the total number
of kilobytes has increased but the
critical path length stayed the same now
as an exercise imagine that each round
trip took one full second because you're
in a really slow connection how long do
you think it would take for us to render
something on the screen see two round
trips 1 second each 2 seconds or so yep
now imagine you're on the latest
superfast fiber connection with 50
millisecond round-trip time seriously
now you're asking you what's 2 times 50
milliseconds yeah that's going to be a
hundred milliseconds it's a good
exercise now you have a good
approximation for how long the page will
take to render and it only took a
minimal amount of analysis